described as a historic moment g7
leaders pledged their collective might
to a plan to fight future pandemics
the carbus bay declaration aims to
develop vaccines in under 100 days
to build better scientific surveillance
techniques and to beef up
powers for the world health organization
but some were
eager to stress that the current
pandemic is not yet over
we need really those was that the power
to come together
and to organize an effective response
to the covet and the only way to be
effective in response to the covet
is guarantee that everybody will
vaccinate it sooner rather than late
the key thing to remember however is
that the pandemic is raging
right now people need doses right now
and crucially countries need financing
right now and every single announcement
we've seen from this g7 so far comes
without any extra money
and until we see the money none of this
unfortunately can be credible
big promises sometimes empty are often a
feature of big summits
this one though had something to offer
that does feel substantial
the united states have said before we're
back the us is back we feel
very very strongly about the cohesion of
nato and
i for one think that the european union
is an incredibly strong and
vibrant entity joe biden's
administration wants g7 allies to
support
a global infrastructure project to rival
china's belt and road initiative
it's a return to u.s leadership that
many of his fellow leaders have sorely
missed
even if warm words for the eu won't be
entirely to the taste of the summit's
host
boris johnson said at the outset that
this g7 summit would be an opportunity
to reaffirm the values that bind these
seven
developed world democracies and yet at
this very summit
he stands accused by the european union
of failing to honour his own commitments
on brexit in a series of meetings eu
leaders have told
johnson that better relations will only
come if he abides by the terms of
post-brexit trade arrangements in
northern ireland
and the u.s president with irish roots
appears to be on their side
i think that we'll have some pragmatic
solutions and
if we don't then i think that what
our friends have also understood is that
it's the prime duty of the uk
government to uphold the territorial
integrity of the united kingdom which is
the sound of a prime minister no matter
how isolated and however disappointed
that brexit has cast a cloud over his
summit
nevertheless refusing to back down joe
nahul al jazeera cornwall